which horror icon went back to his day
job after fighting the undead how does a
sequel to the shining finish on a
positive note these disturbing movies
are known for their surprisingly happy
endings
before 2017's get out jordan peele was
known for his gut-busting comedy chops
in kiempeel so when he decided to helm a
horror film it was a bit of a surprise
this resulting film was a massive
success by every metric though beloved
by audiences and critics alike it earned
over 255 million dollars worldwide and
appeal scored the oscar for best
original screenplay the story follows
chris played by daniel kaluya a black
man who visits his white girlfriend's
family for the first time things go from
mildly uncomfortable to deeply
unsettling when he discovers that they
run a secret operation that transfers
the brains of aging white people into
young fit bodies now chris has been
seduced by rose to become their next
victim
after a terrifying visit to the sunken
place chris fights back and dispatches
his girlfriend and her family in a
spectacularly bloody fashion however a
final moment of tension arises when
during chris's bloody escape he sees
flashing lights ahead those well-versed
in horror history not to mention
centuries of racial injustice might
reasonably expect a tragic ending where
our hero is arrested or gunned down
fortunately the vehicle is driven by
chris's tsa agent friend rod played by
lil rel howery the two drive off into
the night leaving the scene of the
grizzly slaughter behind the film even
ends on a moment of levity with rod
telling chris that he should have
listened to him in the first place
i mean i told you not to go in the house
danny boyle's grungy thriller 28 days
later was an instant genre classic when
it hit theaters in 2002. in the film
activists free chimpanzees from a lab
and inadvertently release a virus that
infects people with rage and depending
on who you ask turns them into a form of
zombie
the key difference these creatures
sprint after its prey rather than slowly
shuffling like others of a cinematic elk
weeks after the outbreak jim played by
kylian murphy wakes up from a coma into
a world he no longer recognizes before
long he's teamed up with some fellow
survivors as they attempt to reach a
safe haven promised by radio broadcasts
things go from bad to worse however when
it turns out that the military regiment
sending the messages is trying to lure
female survivors in with a misguided
plan to repopulate the world jim rescues
his new friends from the twisted
soldiers by unleashing an infected man
upon them and the result is a
blood-soaked finale in which jim is shot
even though they escape surely nothing
but horror awaits them in a world where
mankind's savage nature has run this
rampant right not so as the last moments
of the film show the characters
recovering in a pleasant cottage and
suggests that they may be saved by a
passing fighter jet though we know that
things eventually go badly again in a
sequel 28 weeks later the survivors of
this film seem like they've gotten past
the worst of it
ready or not was directed by matt
bettinelli open and taylor gillette of
the filmmaking collective radio silence
who went on to find even greater success
with their reboot of the scream
franchise the 2019 thriller stars samara
weaving as grace a newlywed who's
marrying into the wealthy ledomos family
after the wedding her new in-laws
revealed that she must participate in
their long-standing tradition of playing
a game in order to officially join their
ranks unfortunately for all involved
grace draws the card for hide and seek
it turns out the lydomus got their
fortune through an ancient satanic pact
when a new family member draws this card
the rest of the clan must arm themselves
and hunt her down in order to provide a
blood sacrifice this leads to a
desperate quest for survival as grace
looks for a way to flee their mansion
while evading her murderous in-laws as
dawn approaches and the family gets more
frantic she finds increasingly violent
ways to turn the tables on them near the
end of the film grace is captured and
the remaining family members rushed to
finish the blood ritual before the sun
rises however she manages to escape
their clutches just in time for the
ritual to fail apparently this causes
all the members of the family to
spontaneously explode in a manner that's
both horrific and comedic at the same
time grace sits back and relaxes as a
mansion burns behind her having dodged a
bullet by not becoming part of such a
deranged legacy
jesus christ what happened to you
in-laws
based on a novel by john iver der
lindquist the swedish film let the right
one in attracts a unique relationship
between oscar and la he's a 12 year old
loner who's been relentlessly bullied
and she's the strange girl who moves
into his apartment building over time
they build a cute friendship that seems
like it could blossom into something
resembling young love there's only one
wrinkle la is a vampire and has been
trapped in a young body for a number of
years she's dependent on an older
guardian to hunt down potential victims
and collect blood for her though the
story has a sweet emotional center when
it concerns the bond between its young
leads there is still a deeply disturbing
undercurrent to the proceedings la's
guardian is captured and arrested while
attempting to procure blood for her and
ends up pouring acid on his face and
jumping from a hospital window to avoid
compromising her safety this leads later
after hunt for her own food which leads
to retaliation from members of the local
community even outside of the
supernatural elements there's also the
problem of oscar's desire to kill the
kids who frequently torment him when he
does finally strike back they respond by
attempting to drown him in a swimming
ball fortunately la comes to his rescue
and gruesomely dispatches them all
despite this incredibly bloody climax
the film still has time for an
optimistic final scene featuring the two
on a train running away towards her own
personal happily ever after
2020 the invisible man is a loose
adaptation of the hd wells novel from
insidious and sore co-creator lee
wennell the film jettisons virtually
everything about the original story
outside of the core premise that a man
can become invisible rather than
portraying the events from his
perspective the film instead centers on
his main victim ex-girlfriend cecilia
who was trapped in an abusive and toxic
relationship before escaping although
she is told that her former boyfriend
died after she left him cecilia doesn't
believe that he's really gone sure
enough she finds herself tormented by an
unseen figure who attacks her when no
one is looking and then disappears
making her seem increasingly unstable
the titular invisible man even goes as
far as killing cecelia's sister and
framing her for the murder which lands
her in a psychiatric hospital the kill
counts for this film may be low but the
psychological torture as protagonist
endures more than makes up for it even
after her rex's brother is a mast
wearing the optical body suit that
grants him visibility she still feels
trapped by the violent relationship just
when it seems like she might give in due
to their unborn child she suddenly takes
fate and the invisibility suit into her
own hands by killing her abuser once and
for all she even gets to walk off into
the proverbial sunset after her
detective friend seemingly lets her off
the hook after realizing what she's done
not a bad outcome considering all she
had to go through
it sounded a lot like he killed himself
ridley scott's original alien is a
classic of both the science fiction and
horror genres boasting innovative
special effects and an atmosphere of
tension and claustrophobia
any potential sequel was going to have
its work cut out for it fortunately for
film goers everywhere director james
cameron managed to expand the scale
while maintaining the intimate terror of
what came before the results is aliens
an action-packed masterpiece as beloved
as its predecessor set 57 years after
her initial encounter with a xenomorph
the film finds alan ripley awakened from
hypersleep just in time to assist the
military expedition to the now colonized
lv-426 yes it's the same place where the
deadly species was first discovered
despite traveling with a crew of
hardened marines it doesn't take long
for the creatures to begin taking them
down one by one their advance to
weaponry fails to protect them for long
and soon only a handful are left alive
in a last-ditch attempt to rescue young
newt the colony's only living survivor
ripley goes head-to-head with the
xenomorph queen who is none too thrilled
to have her babies set on fire their
grudge match eventually results in the
queen being blown out of their ship's
airlock and suddenly all seems right
with the world the planet has been
destroyed the aliens are all dead and
ripley even has a new surrogate daughter
the final moments of the film seem
almost hopeful for the future
that is as long as you ignore the rest
of the franchise i'm sorry newt
you don't have to be sorry it wasn't
your fault the collection a 2012 c
quarter 2009's the collector comes from
patrick melton and marcus dunstan who
wrote the feast trilogy and four of the
sore films it's no surprise that the
first film is a grizzly stomach churning
affair involving elaborate booby traps
and insidious torture methods it follows
a mysterious figure who kidnaps his
victims for nefarious purposes the film
ends with him abducting a man named
arkian who is inadvertently released at
the beginning of the sequel this time
around we get a look at the maniacs
hideout an intricate warehouse filled
with all manner of spikes and source
arcane leads a team of mercenaries in
the hopes of retrieving a girl named
elena and before long the majority of
them find themselves torn apart in
increasingly gruesome ways this is to
say nothing of the collection itself a
room filled with abstract sculptures
constructed of preserved human body
parts in the end only arkin and elena
are left and though arkhan is able to
get the upper hand by throwing his
nemesis into a chute it seems like he
might die as the building is consumed by
fire fortunately elena is able to create
a path to safety by smashing up the
glass cases of the collection spilling
out the water within it's a triumphant
scene of survival set to rock music that
contrasts with the grimness of the rest
of the film arkhan is even able to track
down and abduct the collector himself
with the intention of making sure he
can't hurt anybody else
author stephen king may not be the
biggest fan but few adaptations of his
works are more iconic than stanley
kubrick's the shining the slow burn
chiller cast a spell over decades of
moviegoers with its iconic setting and
memorable characters crafting a sequel
was going to be a tall order for any
filmmaker enter mike flanagan who had
already adapted king's words with
gerald's game and impressed the world
with his the haunting of hill house
series on netflix flanagan took the
sequel novel dr sleep and was able to
find a happy middle ground between
respecting king's writing and paying
homage to the beloved film the story
follows danny torrance now grown up and
played by ewan mcgregor as he struggles
to overcome his childhood trauma as well
as come to terms with his psychic gifts
he also becomes a mentor of sorts to a
young girl with similar abilities named
abra when she's targeted by a gang of
psychic vampires dany does what he can
to protect her as a last resort he takes
her to the overlook hotel where he
re-experiences the horrors of his youth
though he is able to unleash the many
spirits contained there against rose he
ends up sacrificing both himself and the
hotel which burns to the ground as ambra
escapes despite this seemingly dark
conclusion abra is later able to commune
with dany's ghost who tells her that
everything is going to be all right and
to use her power for good
shine on abrastone
you shine on sam raimi's the evil dead
is the stuff of hollywood legend shot
for a measly 375 thousand dollars and
launched the careers of both raymie and
star bruce campbell thanks to creative
filmmaking and an unsettling atmosphere
the pair reunited for evil dead 2 which
utilized this improved budget to create
even more scares and gore effects as
well as introducing a darkly comedic
tone ash williams may have been fighting
for his life against the souls of the
damned but his plight still managed to
be downright wacky at times this
trajectory accelerated even further with
the third film army of darkness which
sees ash transported to the middle ages
and leading a band of medieval warriors
against the horrors of the dead
admittedly this is the silliest of the
trilogy with several moments lifted
directly from the three stooges even
with the lighter tone it still has
plenty of disturbing content including
the army of skeletons led by ash's evil
doppelganger whose skin has been removed
from his face entirely leading to a
fearsomely gruesome visit though many
lives are lost ash is ultimately
successful at defeating evil and
returning to the present day in a
humorous epilogue he has returned to his
department store job and even though
dead eyed still show up to attack him
he's always ready with his trusty
boomstick
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one